are you tired of remembering tons of
passwords or concerned about hacking
attempts on your valuable data then this
video is for you the world we live in is
becoming increasingly digital and with
that comes the increased risk of
security breaches and cyber attacks one
way to combat this is by using
authentication systems that verify the
user's identity before allowing them to
access to your systems in this video we
will explore why authentication is
important and how it can protect your
data authentication is a process of
verifying a user's identity before
allowing them to access to a system or
resource by using authentication systems
you can ensure that only authorized
users have access to your data
preventing unauthorized access or use by
hackers authentication comes in many
forms including passwords tokens and
biometric identifiers two very important
ways of implementing authentication are
multi-factor authentication and
two-factor Authentication MFA and 2fa
are both methods of securing access to a
system but they approach Security in
different ways 2fa requires the user to
enter a password and provide an
additional authentication form such as a
one-time code sent to their phone MFA
requires the user to provide two or more
forms of authentication before gaining
access to a system or application the
importance of authentication cannot be
overstated with the increasing usage of
digital systems the risk of cyber
attacks have been higher and the choice
between MFA and 2fa ultimately comes
down to an organization's specific
security needs and budget each method
has advantages and disadvantages the
best option depends on the circumstances
so if you want to learn more about these
two authentication methods and how to
implement stay tuned with us until the
end of this video and before we begin if
you are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security that
is by graduating from the best
universities for a professional who
elicits to switch careers with cyber
security by learning from the experts
then try giving a shout to Simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT schwarzman College
of Engineering and the course link is
mentioned in the description box that
will navigate you to the course page
where you can find a complete audio of
the program being over and if these are
the types of videos you would like to
watch then hit the Subscribe button like
and press the Bell icon to never miss on
further content so let's delve into the
agenda of our tutorial so first we'll
explore the concept of authentication
and its importance in cyber security We
Begin by defining authentication as the
process of verifying the identity of a
user or entity it involves three factors
that is knowledge possession and
inherence knowledge refers to something
the user knows such as a password
possession involves something the user
owns like a smartphone inherence relates
the biometric traits like fingerprints
we then discuss the limitations of
single Factor authentication that is
primarily relying on passwords Within
increasing sophistication of cyber
threats single Factor authentication is
no longer sufficient to protect
sensitive information this leads us to
explore two-factor authentication and
multi-factor authentication 2fa requires
users to provide two authentication
factors while MFA demands two or more
factors these additional layers of
authentication and hand security and
mitigate the risk associated with single
Factor authentication and the script
also addresses the question of whether
MFA is more secure than 2fa the answer
depends on the specific authentication
methods used in each case both MFA and
2fa can be effective if implemented
correctly incorporating strong
authentication factors finally we
briefly introduce 5f authentication
which includes additional factors like
behavioral and locational based
authentication while these factors
provide supplementary layers of security
they are not widely adopted due to their
early development stage and potential
vulnerabilities overall in this tutorial
we aim to educate yourself about the
importance of authentication the
differences between 2fa and MFA and the
considerations involved in choosing the
right authentication method to protect
personal and organizational data in the
digital age so starting with the
introduction so did you know that nearly
8 billion passwords have been leaked
it's a constant reminder to be hygienic
and responsible with our user
credentials unfortunately the internet
and dark web are filled with exposed
passwords in today's video we'll explore
the importance of authentication and the
role of two-factor authentication and
multi-factor authentication in keeping
our data secure so we'll start with what
is authentication before we delve into
the authentication methods let's clarify
what authentication actually means
authentication is the process of
verifying a user's claimed identity
ensuring that they are who they say they
are and authenticator so an
authenticator on the other hand is a
software device or token that aids in
this process authenticators can come in
various forms such as mobile apps
smartphones code generators or even
wearable devices that provide a one-time
password or a pin for authentication
first there's a single Factor
authentication which relies only on a
password or pin then we have two Factor
authentication that is also known as
two-step verification which requires two
authentication factors for successful
user authentication finally there's a
multi-factor authentication MFA which
prompts the user to provide two or more
authentication factors adding an extra
layer of security now let's take a
closer look at the three factors of
authentication that are involved in
board 2fa and MFA the first factor is
knowledge which refers to something the
user knows such as password or pin and
the second factor is possession which
involves something the user owns that is
like a hardware token smart card or or
smartphone the third factor is inherence
which relies on biometric authentication
such as fingerprint or face recognition
and now you'll see why a single Factor
authentication not enough this is the
single Factor authentication method and
this is not sufficient now so while
relying solely on a password process
significant security risk cyber
criminals have various methods to
correct password such as key logging
phishing and Brute Force attacks that's
why 2fa nmfa Solutions are essential for
strengthening security to Vector
authentication and multi-factor
authentication are inexpensable
components of the cyber security
ecosystem although they may sound
similar they have distinct differences
today we'll explore the disparity
between these two authentication method
and answer the question of whether MFA
is better than 2fa or node now let's
talk about two Factor authentication or
2fa as the name suggests it requires
users to provide two factors us to
identify themselves the first factor is
typically a password something the user
knows the second Factor can be something
the user has like a smartphone or a
token to further verify their identity
the second Factor can take various forms
not just physical devices it could be a
code sent via email or text message
additionally security questions or even
a unique key known only to the user
implementing the second Factor adds an
extra layer of security making it harder
for threat actors to gain access in case
of password leakage now moving on to
multi-factor authentication or MFA as
the name implies it involves multiple
authentication factors MFA is a more
robust user access management tool
combining different types of security
elements and it may require a password a
confirmation code and a biometric data
to confirm the user's identity these
factors can be categorized into
knowledge factors that is passwords or
security questions or possession factors
that is second one that includes
Hardware devices mobile apps or otps and
the next is inherence vectors that is
Biometrics or context vectors based on
user location so by providing complex
evidence from various sources MFA
enhances security and reduces the risk
of unauthorized access so now we will
discuss is MFA more secure than 2fa so
the answer is that it depends the
security of both MFA and 2fa relies on
the authentication methods used if an
MFA implementation combines multiple
strong authentication methods such as
pen that is a knowledge
OTP and fingerprint it can offer a
higher level of security however there
can be scenarios where a 2fa method with
just a push notification and fingerprint
can be more secure than an MFA method
requiring three factors ultimately the
security level depends on the specific
authentication methods employed to sum
it up more two-factor authentication and
multi-factor authentication are
essential Tools in securing our
sensitive data well 2fa requires two
factors of authentic further by
incorporating multiple factors MFA
offers higher security but both methods
are more secure than relying solely on a
single password now let's talk about
balance between security and friction in
authentication methods adding layers of
security doesn't always mean increased
friction with the widespread use of
mobile devices Security checks can be
performed seamlessly without burning the
end user for example location based
authentication can be achieved without
any user intervention the key is to
strike the right balance by using the
most secure authentication methods with
the least amount of friction so this is
the balance between security and
friction in authentication methods so
now we'll see a 5fa authentication
method so you guys may be wondering what
about 5fa or five Factor authentication
so what does this entail we'll see now
so in addition to the previously
mentioned knowledge possession and
inherence Factor so in addition to the
previously mentioned knowledge
possession and inherence factors 5fa
incorporates two more authentication
factors that is behavioral and location
however it's important to note that
behavioral authentication is still in
its early stages and using it as the
sole factor of authentication may carry
risk similarly location-based
authentication can be easily spoofed
using vpns these additional factors
currently serve as supporting layers of
authentication and aren't explicitly
regulated and when choosing the right
authentication method for your company
consider factors such as productivity
existing security measures and budget
striking the right balance is crucial to
ensure efficient and effective security
and this was all for this session thank
you for joining us today as we explore
the world of authentication and the
differences between 2fa and MFA remember
implementing strong authentication
measures is a vital step in safeguarding
your data and with that we have reached
the end of this tutorial and let's take
a minute to hear from our Learners who
have experienced massive success in
their careers hi I'm Philip I'm 61 years
old and last year I upskilled with
simple Learners post program at cyber
security after working 30 years in the
IIT sector in various different profiles
I'm happy to tell you that I was able to
clear and pass my cissp and ccsp
certification exams on the first attempt
after taking the course course I must
say was packed with practical examples
it was led by highly skilled certified
instructors with many companies before
the security analysts and the architect
on a contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with Infosys as a cyber
security consultant happened on the
first and if you have any questions
please feel free to comment and we'll
have it answered for you as soon as
possible until next time thank you for
watching stay safe keep learning and get
ahead staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign